all right let's do drama queens and
energy vampires we kind of talked a
little bit about drama queens in that
last one didn't we
yeah exactly and um i think that
the energy vampire bit comes about
because it's just so exhausting
to deal with somebody like that you know
and it's it's kind of
what you were just describing this up
and down this that
sort of one minute she's like this then
the next minute she's like that
it's really exhausting and it's actually
a form of
passive aggressiveness actually i mean i
mean there are i've
actually read uh books or articles not
as part of this space but
by more sort of mainstream kind of you
know relationship advisors and they
would actually
deem it to be abusive if somebody treats
you in that manner you know if you've
got somebody who
say giving the silent treatment for
example i mean this is a really classic
thing isn't it you she
she's obviously upset about something
you've done
something and you say to her so what's
wrong and she just won't tell you
you're like no come on what's wrong why
are you being like yeah
yeah fine and she's like that she's i'm
fine
and then she just won't talk to you and
it goes on for hours and hours and
hours i mean on the one hand you could
just say well that's just you know how
she is or whatever but but actually
really it's a form of passive aggressive
behavior and it's actually quite
with an emphasis perhaps on the
aggressiveness actually because it makes
the per the other person feel really bad
and it arguably
it's kind of abusive so really you don't
want to be putting up with that on a
long term basis i mean
if it happens time and again then you if
your app is occasionally fine whatever
but
like if that's happening on a consistent
basis then that you know most
importantly
it's sapping your energy and it's
sapping your mental
space that could better be devoted to
something else you know because a lot of
this stuff is crap you know a lot of
this stuff is like oh well you didn't do
the washing up three weeks ago and then
you know
i had to go buy the milk and you know
it's all it's all it's all nonsense
it's all just rubbish you know and this
is one of the problems i found with
relationships in my life that you get
dragged into this
domestic minutiae which when you
or you know oh we didn't go to see my
parents last weekend and now
we're going to see your parents you know
it's all it's all nonsense it's got
nothing to do with your key purpose in
life
whatever that might be you know and i
just keep coming back to the same thing
it's like well i'm only here for
a few more decades i'm going to be dead
quite soon there are certain things i
want to accomplish in my life is arguing
about this stuff going to get me nearer
to those things or further away
and inevitably the answer is going to
get me further away
yeah i think that's a very very good way
of framing it because um
actually cover uh drama queens
i i more or less coined them
um hissy fits because that's really what
they are they
like women will throw hissy fits
uh when they don't know how to process
uh
stress or moments in the relationship
that they can't control or they can't um
you know adapt to um and hissy fits come
in all kinds of different forms you know
like you said it could be passive
aggressive stuff
it could be something as extreme as
we'll just leave all my [ __ ] on the
front porch and i'm gonna come pick it
up and fu sort of thing right
yeah you know they want to try to put
their foot down to
um show that they've got some frame or
or something going on and really the
best way to deal with it is just to soft
next it you know
yeah drama that shows up in your life
you soft next that you know you
you know you just withdraw your
attention because we know that attention
is the coin of the realm
when it comes to women and when you
remove the attention
um you know you set a firm boundary
essentially saying look you know if you
want to behave this way fine
i'm not going to give you any of my
attention you know she's going to call
you she's going to text you she might
even try to show up you just ignore it
all
um and it's as simple as that energy
vampires you're gonna know when you're
around an energy vampire because would
you spend time with them and this also
goes for guys as well too
um you know employees business partners
i mean you'll start to notice this
throughout life when you spend time with
somebody it could be a few hours it
could be an afternoon
for example but when you spend time with
them you feel drained after it
you feel exhausted being around their
personality and the sort of
conversations that they want to have
you don't feel energized like when i
have a conversation with troy if we do
with cass we did a cast last week on his
channel
and we talk about stuff and we kind of
chop up ideas i feel good after the
conversation right i want to have
another conversation with troy and kind
of dive down a different rabbit hole or
maybe
you know take a look at something else
so he's not an energy vampire if
anything
the guy charges my batteries and i hope
that he gets the same sort of energy
from me back
on the end of it but you will know when
you're around energy vampires because
you're just going to feel exhausted by
the end of that day
yeah absolutely um and if you're feeling
that then you need to to get out of it
but again you see this is
one of the things that abundance is so
important right because
if you're a guy that doesn't have much
abundance if you're a guy who
who doesn't feel that his options are
that extensive then it's more likely
that earlier on in your life you're
going to get locked down with a woman
who's like this
and you're probably going to end up like
moving in with her or you know whatever
or even
god forbid getting married to her and
then you're screwed
or at least you're in a much more
difficult position than you would be if
you kept your options
open at least for a period of time
you